this is a production of Cornell
University yeah thank you everybody for
having me my time cor now so Neil
mentioned my being at H Riverside I was
in to sh lab if you know Ms Sals which
is culture that's the lab I came from
and he was really unhappy to Ed side
back in in the previous 70s and he
always threatened about coming to
Cornell he would bring his whole Lab
group so I did a lot of research about
coming Corell that so that would have
been my linkage toow Cornell but so but
now this is my first time being here 40
years later 50 years later okay so let's
talk about this project developing
landscape plan uh irrigation
recommendations for the Western us I'm
going to we're going to talk about some
background of how this got started how
this research L research in my lab got
started it was specifically centered
around uh regulations and uh water
conservation and landscapes in the state
and then I'll of course describe the
studies um how we set up the experiment
because that in our in this case it's
really I think unique how we collect
data how we present results could
extension specialist I have to provide
Outreach and extension and then uh the
current project is now it's a
multi-state project um talk about some
future work that's coming up and then
what the impacts have been of This
research on the
industry so let's get started with
background so in California there's this
regulation Statewide ordinance called
the model water efficient landscape
ordinance uh it was actually initiated
in 2010 so it's pretty old uh but you
know water in California is always a
peral
issue and so this ordinance comes into
play when uh building perit is needed so
if you renovate a landscape and you uh
do some work that that requires building
permit then that triggers the S if you
build a new landscape commercial or
residential then that triggers the
ordinance because of buing from
required so in this ordinance you have
to estimate the the any water use for
the new landscape of course it fars some
math uh then you have to compare it to a
another measure of um that would be the
allowed volume of water and do the
comparison if the estimated water uses
than all you have to make adjustments
we'll go into detail about how these
calculations are
done okay so here's the uh the estimated
total water use for the new landscape is
this formula this is Formula was
developed by the Department of Water
Resources the agency that's uh enforcing
this regulation and so these variables
are uh the estimated total water use
reference ET this is a conversion factor
plant factor is the plant factor for the
particular plant that's in the landscape
so you might think of it as a species
coefficient for crops uh ha is the the
hydrozone area or the irrigated area I
is the irrigation efficiency you might
think of that as the distribution
uniformity of the irrigation
system and then SLA are is a allowance
for special landscape areas so this
would be vegetable gardens areas that
are being irrigated replanted water
where they were be allowance for all
allowing more water use in those
areas so this is the that estimated
Total War use for a
year the uh plant factor is the issue uh
so just recall this uh remember this
this acur wal we'll talk about this in
more detail so these numbers come from
this document and I'll go into that in a
little one so the comparison number is
the maximum applied water allowance or
MAA and that's this formula so again uh
reference ET conversion factor EF this
is now a ET conversion factor or
allowance factor for uh residential or
commercial you can see it's 0.55 for
residential and
045 times for the commercial so it's
essentially the allowable water use is
55% of the water that the reference prop
would use for residential
45% of the watties for the reference
prod this quantity over here is the
allowance for um the special landscape
area so it's adding back that
subtraction to the special landscape
area so it's you see it's a lot of map
homeowners if they trigger this permit
permitting process they're expected to
do this map Landscape Architects and
designers are usually the ones that uh
have to submit permits and uh guide the
homeowner through this process the
county or city Municipal people are the
ones have to review this and they have
to also understand the maap and to be
able to enforce it um the tricky part
though is this etaf and then that PL
factor that we talked about
earlier so again you compare the two
values if the estimated total water use
is greater than the the maximum water
allowance and you have to adjust a
landscape to reduce the water use to
make that that
fit so talking about the plant
Factor this is language from the
ordinance it says the plant factor used
shall be from wals or from horiculture
researchers with acade academic
institutions or professional
associations as approved by the
California Department of Water Resources
so I put this part in bold here because
this part was added later after we
started our research and we started
submitting our plants for our numers
into this
document the original language did not
include this parameter or this parameter
it just said plant Factor shall be from
WS now when you put this kind of
language in an
ordinance sh is a really strict term it
has to come from this document with the
unintended consequences of dwr were is
that you can't use any other plants
unless they are in this list
but they're not in this list and you
can't get the plant Factory back then
there was only 1,900 plants in this list
in California there's an estimate wild
estimates of wide ranging estimates of
10 to 20,000 cultivars of plants using L
they had it down to the c bar level yes
yeah so I want to talk about what this
wles
is so this stands for the L W CL
classifications of landscape species
that's currently in version
four uh it is a searchable database of
landscape plants in California it does
include plant factors that I'll describe
uh in more detail a little bit currently
it has 3500 plants and it is now being
updated deinos got a grant now to update
it originally version three was 1900
plants they' got to expend 3500 plants
still not enough U but I I think they're
trying to push down 4 5,000 but still
not enough but it's more than
1900 so here are the URLs for these
documents I think if you if you just use
locals as a search term you there's
nothing else called
loal so you'll get it uh you'll get
version four I put this one up here
local
.pdf this is version three this one is
really important because it's in two
sections the first section of it is
called the landscape full efficient
method so it talks about how to use this
information how different different
factors in Landscapes affect plant water
use canopy density uh plant density
slopes aspect things like that how all
these factors affect the microclimates
and and and water usage so it's a really
good um uh learning guide for people in
landscape trying to understand manage
landscape
irrigation so the way that this list
these lists were developed um focus
groups were uh formed of particle
cultural experts in six different in
each of six different climate zones
these are Divine defined by the
Department of Water
Resources so these focus groups and
these horiculture experts are I consider
plant gods they they just know plants
really well if I need information on a
plant I go to one of these people they
really know plants in
California they reviewed plant lists and
then you categorize those plants by vot
uh into these uh these these categories
high high moderate low very very low
water you youve seen they attach these
ranges of reference
ET factors into to these descriptive
labels so they really don't have a plant
Factor but they have a range so what
Landscape Architects and people do to
comply with this ordinance guess which
number they use they use the lowest one
right to make sure that they compile
well that's it's which what I would do
um but just keep in mind to these ranges
so 0. 2.5 and point8 are the mid-ranges
of these of these U these
Distributors because that will come up
later in in our
experiments so that brings up the the
research project the um in California we
call the landscape the UC landscape PL
irrigation trials the acronym as UCP pit
um if you Google you see help pit you
can probably get our our web page and
the objective of this project was to
actually develop these plant factors um
by using research methods inste of focus
groups so you can see a picture of the
one of the fields here where uh you can
see different irrigation lines there's
three irrigation lines each delivering a
treatment to um to the plants in the
field so it's the plants are randomized
the treatments are
randomized
the uh reference ET number that we get
is from simus which is the California
irrigation management information system
and it just turns out that this system
in California was developed in the I
think late 1970s by Rick Snider who's a
biom meteorologist on campus it's a
Statewide system for to support um
agronomic CRS in the state to help them
manage more precisely irrigation there
happens to be a simus weather station on
campus uh it's only about a mile and a
half from our site so we use that
information and we actually had Rick
come out and uh do us conduct a study of
our site and give us some factors so we
can tweak that number even further for
our site because it's not a typical uh
monocultural crop U and it's uh it's
just different than an agronomic
crop so the treatments we use are uh
these factors of ET again those
mid-ranges of those um of those the
scriptors on those with those ranges of
B that were
attached originally we started with 20
4680 because they were nice divisions of
of the V uh we had five treatment it
wasn't robust we weren't getting good
statistical results uh so and for two
reasons we changed it to match those
descriptors and wles and to increase the
number of replicates to eight where we
get better statistical um
uh Power um we changed it to 2080
5080 and it's been like that for 15
years
now so one of the first steps is we need
to know about the soil I you know about
this web called soil web this app called
soil web it's a digitized version of the
USGS so surveys uh it's really cool out
if you all your phones have GPS now you
can uh
activate this app and it will tell you
the soil type it's a really cool
app and the the factor that we use in it
there's a plant available water Factor
that's listed in the um the soil
description of your soils and so we
irrigate the the the plants with a fixed
volume most other irrigation type trials
for at least for landscape plants they
might have a fix schedule of irrigation
and then they vary them volume of water
that's applied to M GT which is the
wrong thing to do we tell people
irrigate deeply and infrequently so we
irrigate with a fixed volume but the
interval between application varies
based on the so that's what makes that
this this project different so knowing
what the plant available water is uh we
have a 50% amount manageable management
allowable depletion so when half of Paws
get depleted then that's when we rebuild
um
water you know you know what happens if
you go you have plants
right so we just use this generalized uh
this guideline that's pretty commonly
used uh for our
trigger okay so like I said the interval
between irrigation varies with weather
based on ET and for an example in 2019
the trip our irrigation season is
between April and September uh we get
essentially zero rainfall in this in
this period in our area California um we
get 80% of our rainfall occurs in 90
days from December and February so we
know in California we haven't filled
that
precipitation bottle that gas tank we're
in trouble um we had a miracle March one
year uh when uh February was really dry
up till February was really dry we had
March we fill we had all all that snow
pack that saved us but normally we don't
have that and again so April mid April
September is our irrigation season you
can see what the number of irrigations
and the interval between irrigations are
so 36 days between irrigations in
California it's a long time it's a month
between irrigations when we were first
doing setting up the experiments we were
coming up with these numbers
20% we're been killing a lot of PLS and
the surprising thing is don't really
don't so data collection um we take uh
uh one set of physical measurements uh
we have a plant growth index where we um
measure the width of the plant in two
Dimensions perpendic to each other and
then the height and we come up with this
plant growth index uh this is Jared say
n he's the
project manager this is probably him
when he was a soptware undergraduate so
he's been working with me
for 11 years now he's a he was a staff
research associate so staff researcher
now he decided to go back after lots of
prod to get his graduate degree so uh so
we do this once a month uh year one is
plant establishment so we typically
plant put PL ground in November of the
Year November through about uh February
mid-February during the winter that
first summer is an establishment year we
give the plants about the 80% treatment
irrigation to make sure that they get
established uh the management of all use
25% to make sure we don't kill the
plants because they're they're still
young and then just goes through the
second winter the second irrigation
season is when we apply the treatments
and during that treatment um season then
we also collect this qualitative uh
information so overall appearance Fage
Fage quality flowering we actually
collect this twice a month P resistance
disease resistance and vigor so these
These are of course qualitative we have
well- defined blits for five steps
within each of the each of these
parameters oops we also have openhouse
Field Days um um preco we in Davis and
Southern California we would have three
events spring summer and fall we would
invite Horticulture professionals Master
Gardeners anybody that
had more experience with gardening we
wouldn't invite the general
public we invite them to come out to the
fields we see a group of them um in our
field we would ask them to rate the
plants for for performance what we would
do was we would pick a plant um a best
looking plant of a treatment and we
would tag that in in our field and we
would ask the the visitors to to rate
those plants we typically get between 50
and 80 people in for an event and it
takes about an hour and a half or so to
V and so what we do is we uh collect
this U this information from these
ratings um and then we will combine
those ratings with our monthly data that
we collect and see how they cooperate
some take some go we also ask ask
questions about what your favorite
plants were which ones do you you like
which one do you think that you would
probably use in the future in your
projects just to see
what here's our website um this is a
you're going to be seeing some
screenshots so I know some of the texts
won't be readable but uh uh I'll try to
I will um have a blow blow ups of
enlargements of the text that I like you
to see so this is just the home page you
can see there's contact us our contacts
Award winners there's a plant index of
all the plants we've tested history of
that the projects how we do the research
uh there are written reports that we put
together every year uh for uh funding
agencies so those are here and then
there's some other stuff
here so here's the again if you if you
do a search of UCL that you'll probably
come to our site because there's nothing
else called that I want to go to these
Award winners um just pull down here
actually I'm sorry um further down on
this page there's you we get a lot of
indries for I talked about uh plants
that uh that are included in the I
haven't talked about plants that are
included in the project but originally
we started out with some plants that
were selected by the arum um then we
expanded it out to the industry plant
Developers PL readers uh if they wanted
to for us to develop information on
their plants we would offer space to
them for for a small fee like 500 bucks
per plant it actually cost us we banded
between $1600 and $1,800 $2,000 per
plant to do these studies for the time
materials
things so these are some of the
companies that have um uh submitted
plants and that we collected information
on ball ornament Min was was the first
um company to submitted plants for our
trials and they submit plants every year
uh and you know now that star roses and
plants is part of that that group
um hin Horticulture now is uh called The
Verdict
Growers um treetown USA company bought
all the Hinds nurseries and Consolidated
the their their nurseries and Verity
Growers uh they submit plants here year
and you can see some other plants that
are probably
um uh recognizable a village Nursery is
part of that averity um
team so I want to pull down these Award
winners we have a several categories of
Blue Ribbon winners which I'll talk
about more dep so these are the plants
that uh have performed well so our
rubrics our rating rubrics are is a 1 to
five score five is a perfect plant so if
plant did well that the 20% treatment
and have score four or larger or higher
they were selected as a blue ribbon
winner happy mediums if they did well at
50% treatment then they fall in this
this group People's Choice Awards the
visitors that come uh we had asked them
what their favorite plants are and
that's that list and then staff picks
are our
favorites so I want to talk about a
little more about U what's in these
lists and I I want to go to the Blue
Ribbon winners and this is a description
of that page we have a logo that's
associated with those those plants um
and you can see this is 2021 data we
haven't actually put in our 2022 data
yet and I'll explain that later in the
in the talk why we haven't done that yet
but you can see there's uh some
interesting winners there's L mandra and
three roses on this place the Roses do
really well at the
water and is it just one year then I
mean you have the establishment year and
then you trials and then plow everything
under
and refurbish the field and put another
CR we do have crops now we have one
field so a little more detail of about
this field but the plants are under 2
met by 2 met
spacing some of the plants uh annoyingly
until the developers are get really
large so we have another field that's
3x3 M uh we be put in plants that we
suspect are going to be larger and the
last year we've actually let that field
go to a second
evaluation we always have that question
what happens in second
year but you this this takes a lot of
space yeah and space at universities you
know means not
right so this is just up love that page
just seeing pointing out the two Lous
PCS or Club bars the three Rose and we
have a separate list for UC Davis Blue
Ribbon W winners and the a list for the
plants tant Southern California I I'll
have a description of this location
later
to so if we click on the UC Davis list
we get another page this is another page
of all the plants that we that made this
Blue Ribbon um a winter we have a 50%
shade house where we test M and dry
shade so that's uh we to um um note
where the plants were tested whether
it's in shade or sun year it was tested
what the mean overall appearance rating
was so the this award is based on this
overall appearance rating because that's
what people want they want to see what
the
visual impact
is so just to get some if these are all
these are all live uh links U this is a
selection of one so this alliv Martini
at elag
I'm not an alag fan but this one was
pretty cool so this is a picture of it
in in Davis There's a summary of what it
looked like how it performed in the
field we have some uh some dat was who
was submitted by where it was what field
a year uh the year the size at the end
of two years of
growth what the plant submitter suspects
the maternity side would be size of
material would be wles plant type wles
has categories of plant type shrubs
trees um Ground Covers
Etc uh these
uh this recommendation is uh for the
different regions the that the dwr
climate regions region two and three um
and what our recommendations are for
water needs and then what the overall
scores were for the appearance ratings
at UC Davis and at South Coast in
southern
Califor and that's the this is the
essentially the the information that a
PL planner would would be using for
their their landscapes for that that
ordinance to u to calculate those
numbers so also have we put in some data
too because people sometimes want to see
thata most people don't but some people
do so this is the the uh the rating
categories the treatments and the the
numbers the ratings by month and then
the average for those months so you can
see this uh this plant had really high
ratings for all three
treatments we also put in the data that
the open house participants um develop
because they don't often they often
don't match ours um and that's okay um
you can kind of see so this you can see
the the only things that we ask for in
the visitors ratings are overall
appearance Fage quality and Florida
because those are the visual
things uh you see the different
treatments in the different seasons U
the thing that's really puzzling here
this is Ali Agnus it's non-flowering but
we did get radi for flowering well
that's one of the reasons why we ask uh
visitors have to do this and then why we
compare it to ours because sometimes you
get some really s things like this
happen but you can see that they
um they didn't rate this quite as high
in the in the fall but in the earlier
parts of the seasons it rated pretty
high so you can see that quality fell
off during during the the irrigation
season here's some data on the U the
fiscal measurements this is uh uh the
the monthly plant growth index number so
you can see that there you can see that
there was a treatment effect maybe but
you know statistic Bally is probably not
significant but the other thing that we
uh do is we do a comparison for relative
PL growth so we
set uh the initial ratings as one and
then these are essentially percentages
of growth uh compared to the original
rating so now can see some really clear
um differences and so this allows for
when you put plants in the ground put we
put 24 plants the ground they're not
identical they don't
um grow even though when you get them
they're pretty close to the same size
they don't establish the same rate they
don't grow the same rate so you get a
lot of variability that's a problem with
Field St D this variability so we found
that by um U comparing these relative
plank grth index indexes that kind of
takes away that variability for those
initial sizes we can get some clear
information on sta the statistics you
can see that this plant was physically
smaller than the higher treatment but
the overall rating appearance ratings
was still really high so and we don't
really care about size I think in the
Landscapes maybe even prefer smaller
plants because of less maintenance and
things like that so this is turned out
to be a really nice really nice PL
here's closeup theage nice glossy green
um f compared to the our
normal pages that we normally
see so this for a little bit history
that I want to get
into um this started out as a master's
thesis research project for carer
student car she actually went on to be a
um County adviser for Horticulture in
California so this was her uh she
finished her thesis in
2004 um and then once she got the um she
finished and we established this UC
plant irrigation trials in 2009 we built
the shade house to do dry shade
plants 2017 we had some funny from the
California Department of food and egg
that allowed us to completely R our
fields in Southern California this is UC
hous research and Extension Center in
Irvine in Southern California is not
associated with UC Irvine people assume
and it's not um so this a picture of
their field in in Southern
California so that allow us to do a
northern California Southern California
comparison we would have the same set of
planks in both locations same treatment
same everything else is the same set the
location and that allowed us to do
Southern California California trains
and that way we'd also make
recommendations based on the different
irrigation recommendations based on the
different parts of the
state in 2020 we got a USDA grant that
allowed us to expand the uh the fields
to replicate the fields at the
University of Washington Oregon State
Utah State and University of Arizona so
now we have six locations across this
really wide latitude Across the Western
us where do these comparisons all the
methods are identical uh we every year
we meet and re review the the rubrics we
actually go out to the field but we all
stand or on the same plan make our our
our comparisons and see if everybody
comes up with the same Source because
that's the other Vari variable is the
the people collecting the data for
especially for Quality data so we try to
standardize that keep that standardized
throughout the
year
and so that's what this allowed is that
we have this this
this standardized method across these
locations that allowed us to to allow us
to evaluate plants uh
performance and then recommend uh the
objective now is to make irate
recommendations for these plants across
these these
locations the other uh objective we have
is and we we offer service to plant
developers and we also teamed up with Dr
Ryan contras that Oregon state was the
oral plant reader there um he's one of
the cop and we allow him to submit
plants for him to for us to evaluate his
plants that he wants to release under
the tree we have we and he's released a
couple from U from these not from the
full state but from the California
valuations he's released a couple on
trade and of course it's an extension
project we want to promote the use of
SP so here's some characteristics some
comparisons about the different
locations uh we can see you can see
there's the difference in USDA zones um
you don't have Sunset zones here would
you have Southern Living is that up
here no we would just have a
us so in Sunset we have these different
climate zones that uh uh also consider
high temp high higher temperatures in in
the regions usk is mostly low
temperatures right right
yeah um and your rainfall water this is
PL available water from U from the soil
web app and then the soil type um
because you all know soil this is really
important to know uh for managing
irrigation and so what the project
objective ours objectives are so we have
subset of plants that we try to select
that we can test at all six sites it's
really difficult to find plant that will
survive in 6 to 10 um and even from six
to to nine is hard hard to find but we
do find some plants because this is a
climate ready landscape plants the the I
guess the overall thought was if I have
a plant that's doing well in
Seattle in 40 years will that plant
still be doing well uh so we want to be
able to answer those kinds of questions
by testing that plant in Davis if it
does well in Davis it'll probably do
well in Seattle in 40 years or
one so that's that's that's
the overall premise then we also have
some Regional testing of other plants
and for example we'll have a subset of
plants that will'll test at Utah
Washington and Oregon and then we might
have another subset of plants that we'll
test in California and Arizona because
those climate zones are are are more
similar
we also might have some plants that
we'll do at uh Davis and Oregon and
Washington for
example so just some information about
who's involved um uh myself and Carrie
of course were The Originators Alexandro
Solus a new new professor in our
department who I hope is going to take
over for me um jar SOS so I point at it
earlier he's a um he's the project
manager
at South Coast um Darren Haver and
Natalie Levy are the pis down there um
I'll talk a little bit more about some
of these pis how the linkages are how
they became
pis Dr to Kim at University of
Washington uh here's Carri Reid um
there's Jared here's Su Kim and three
graduate students in in Sue lab there's
a lot of graduate student involvement
these projects that at the
Oregon State uh this is actually at the
North wam research and Extension Center
in Aurora not in Coralis or just south
of
Portland and Dr Lloyd nley and Ryan
contras are the leads there again here's
Jared again Jared's are Troy Kent a Roy
K you know said last right here there
everywhere uh Utah State up Pink Sun and
chal again here's chal with Jared
looking at this one Rosa did really well
up there this is
20% and in Ursa shuk at the University
of Washington and again Jared um so
these P are
all that's they came out because they're
all really good friends
of I've known Ursula since the 1980s she
was an extension she actually had my job
back in the 1980s and when I was a
grower I knew her then so Kim and I were
in the same lab
Davis um Lloyd nle at organ St was Kim's
first PhD student my first
postto um uh Darren Haver was I knew him
since you was an undergraduate he was
UK's first PhD student and one of my
best friends Darren and um Ying's son um
was I actually invited Larry ret Utah
state was he was a good friend of mine
but he retired St so all my friends
that's why I want to stay involved with
this project so I go visit my friends on
Research so some of the PLS that we test
at all the locations a couple of
hibiscus syus Philadelphia these two
this one and this one are uh Ran's
develop genotypes that he developed and
then a couple of U Rosen Vitex Vex is
becoming a really interesting study for
physiology we found out
2023 perus meanus Salvia Vex and
Rose so when for these PLS we to do
those cross comparisons across all the
sites and then again there's also
subsets of plants that we have within
smaller groups of
locations so other things that allows us
to
do um one of the things I like to say to
all the piis is we have this really cool
infrastructure it's really neat team
there's physiologists are
involved much better physiologists than
I I am or will be um but how do we
exploit this this infrastructure this
team and so uh this allows us to look at
um the plasticity of water stress so we
would take a set of clients that we had
all six sites we try to look at a time
when all treatments would be irrigated
so we would do some physiological
studies just prior to irrigation have
the highest water stress levels and then
24 hours after irrigation 24 48 72 and 7
days after irrigation see how they
recovered and we did that at all six
locations really
neat and then other aspects water stress
uh oops chlorophyll Forest it's model
conductance so that that new lorse 6 um
allows us to conduct these those meurs
really
fast it takes only like 15 seconds to do
both those
measurements and then also Washington
they wanted to look at stodal density to
see if there was any picity associated
with water stress with st density and St
conductance and then we uh we gave up on
St water potential you know that's T
takes a lot of of time it's really hard
p and we didn't really see a lot of um
information from from that study as well
but we we're continuing with with
these uh Vex I wanted to make note in
Vex we found that with Vitex it didn't
matter what treatment they were on or
what stage of the treatment they on the
Stato conducted was always really high
it didn't make any sense and they were
growing really well um what we did
notice also what udub folks noticed is
that when they're under really high
water stress and the some was really
intense they would flip your leaves
because have a lot of troms on the
bottom side of leaves that were lighter
colored so we get those higher
reflectant um but they
still the transpiration still really hot
Lauren are are the emitters like
drippers or is there a ring yeah so
there's there's a drip emitter with a
ring that just distributes the water
around the pl
yeah I've heard a new definition of an
expert an expert is some of the all the
mistakes that could possibly be made and
having done this for 20 years I can say
that we're experts we' all the mistakes
you can
make uh and so additional projects uh we
thought about trees and trees are used
toate Thal mods and buildings that take
a long time to become established become
established to develop any effect so we
submitted our project to usba again and
got funded for uh focusing on
vines uh they Vines grow faster there's
a lot of studies on he heat mitigation
using Vines but none of them look at
water use and that's what we do is look
at mic water use so we put together
these fields you can see there's
um there's each one of these
installations is this two t- bar post
with this uh cattle or five stock C each
location uh has 240 of these installed
so we each one of us pounded 480 these
posts in we tried look at at mechanical
stuff but this way still do under
graduates uh so we measure we will
measure light interception growth rates
and plant water use in this
study there's up to 10 tax per site uh
there's one site but the fields a little
smaller so they can only put in I think
seven uh at all sites are we have uh a
set of plants V water
rolia vonia Mam galin and L G so these
four colars are at all 10 sides and then
we also
have subsets at at different
sites and we we'll start collecting data
in 2024 so 2023 is their establishment
here so you has put together their
website for the climate ready plants and
that's the uh intent is for each
institution to put together their own
website because each institution has
their responsibilities to their instate
clientele so they need to put together
they will be putting together their own
websites uh UC Davis we have a website
that has the just like the project
linkage SES where we have the
description of projects but we link to
all the other um
um websites at the other
institutions there's a lot of extension
the suggested the last couple years uh
Pacific qu culture is a online magazine
um they released three videos on the
project specifically on our project and
how we set it up what our intentions are
what our outcodes are expected
are Utah put together a video and then
there's a few more newsletter blogs and
things like that so it's a a really
short list of what's come
out and then other impacts um there's
this selection of lipia not Flora
grafia so it's a a Turf alternative it's
a western native plant but this
selection is out of Japan and they we've
done testing uh on on this uh I think
they have like four cultiv bars of it
now but I wanted this is a the
screenshot of the website and I will
point out this this text down
here and it says CPP is a highly
versatile UC tested drought tolerant
ground cover Etc so we get recognition
that it's tested at using Davis we have
data shows that it's really a good
performer at little water we think it'll
do well at 10% because just good super
at
20 uh star roses and plants and their
new rose catalog uh just came out a
couple of months ago
uh for this is for their Rose double
knockout you see the Blue Ribbon U logo
there it says winter for out studing low
water performance in 2017 wles trials
which they call our trials they have a
whole page that lists all of their roses
uh drop tolerant roses and I'll blow up
this text up here and it says drought
tolerant roses University California
landscape plant irrigation trials an
important figur trial for trials for
determining heat drop tolerance of
plants varities are grown and monitored
following irrigation percentages in
what's classifications of landscape
species 4 those that exhibit Superior
overalls results on low water are Award
of the Blue Ribbon perform that you see
Davis so we're seeing um a really nice
application or usefulness of this
information I actually just last week I
got a call from May Andros is in France
they want to use the same kind of
language their their
catalog so this is just what we talked
about real quickly uh background the
experiment multi-state project future
working impacts and that's my
talk question
yeah one of my brothers when I was gr up
interested and one of the things talk
about environment they don't lot of
external have you looked into like
colleting data on that on funny should
mention native PLS so the question is
about native plants about information on
on Plants we just submitted a we're
actually we are submitting preparing a
proposal for USDA focusing on native
plants using our sites and we want to
test local native plants Regional versus
so we want to have a set of plants local
native Regional native or cult ours of
natives to see if they how perform
Compares and also pollinator support so
there's a big deal about pollinator
support of a higher diversity of
pollinators on local plants but there's
not a lot of data on that there's some
data but not a lot of thata and
certainly not a lot of data across the
West so we're going to
support first thing you look at look at
grow but what about the impact on like
flowering or yellowing
might still
well
question yeah so the question is about
flowering and foliage quality and
respons and we do measure those so of
those qualitative um measures foliage
quality is one and we look at
U the aesthetic quality of of the
foliage
coloring shaped leaves in also in there
we looked at disease resistance and pest
resistance because that affects Fage and
the other thing we look at is again is
flowering flowering is one parameter we
look at twice a month because we don't
want to miss the flowering Seas we want
to know if it affects
flowering
appearance when the flowers first Marge
or the flowering duration we want to
know that so we look at
those else you might just say out loud
is there any question from Geneva is
there any questions from Geneva how do I
find it Well there there would be a
voice coming from
above okay
AR yeah well you
know anything
else um last year seemed like it was an
unreasonably
wet uh winter in
California um is is that going to mean
that there is that going to like mess up
this Summer's trial I guess it did yeah
yeah so we thought that we would be
killing plants because of over
irrigation or lack of irrigation during
our treatments last year we had this
record rainfall year in
California in let's see it been
September
22 we had a project team Mee meeting in
Davis uh the next day we were going to
have an open housee Fu event and our
project team was going to be present
that was open house fi with we were at
dinner and it just dumped rain and it
rained I think it rained two inches that
night so Jared and I went out to the
field after dinner and it was a
lake so we canceled the event uh that
night went back out the next day and it
was still a lake uh this summer when we
collecting data we lost a lot of Ms and
it was the one year where we were
focusing on desert
PLS and so we lost
complete
CS so out of the 10 species that we
normally test I think we had that on
six did any one time how many uh species
or cultivars you have trial in Davis we
have so because it takes two years we
have two Fields but we have alternating
um planting dates and so we have data
every year so we have two 2 met fields
in the sun we have two 2 met fields in
the shade we have two 3 m fields in the
Sun and we have now we have one u b
field so so in your 2 by two you might
run 40 C bars through each we run we run
10 10 per cycle in the Sun okay in the
shade it's uh four per cycle in the 3
meter field it's five per cycle and then
all the planting is that all with a
shovel by hand you have you have haven't
invented some nice little
machine no we do we have we have access
to labor Crews Farm labor Crews on
campus so we'll hire them to help us do
the pl cultivation like that but and you
know it's a it's a great opportunity for
enterprisers to collect data and do
plant care and stuff like that and the
nurseries must love this right I mean
they would be donating all the plants
I'm sure and they they must be very
excited by all of this we get a lot of
plant donations uh in addition to the
plant donations we ask for that fee $500
$500 is a lot of money so some some
people it is but for the Bigg
compan yeah um we do have when we get
funding from agencies we do set aside
some money for plant
uh to procure plants because there are
some plants that we want to test um
there are some plants that ran wants to
test but he's a researcher so he has to
be funded for probably most PLS
do anything
else as part of the qualitative
assessment can you take a
photo
just vision gets get
better yeah so the question is about
photo documentation and we do a lot of
that until this
year because Carrie retired last year
she was the one doing that and I took
over and I'm not very good at that um
she's a really good Plant photographer
I'm not um but yeah every month she
would take a picture of plants all the
plants on each of the treatments um I
think two times
that and you know that's a lot of
pictures it's a lot of times a lot of
times this has been a production of
Cornell University on the web at
cornell.edu